[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
okay
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
okay
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
oh yeah there we go all right hello
hello everyone how is it going
persia here and today's stream is
brought to you
by truth and the this is waiting program
that they have to help people
quit speaking and if you want to learn
more then you can text
ditchvape to 88709
to learn more about their program which
i will also be telling you about
while we play some amazing island games
okay i said amazing because i've been
so hard working on this island but the
island games
should be super super fun and i'm really
excited and all of our games today are
going to be
kind of enforcing the fact that you can
get through
anything especially ditching basic
right and having a support system and
friends
that can help you along the way and even
this is quitting to help you along the
way
can make all the difference this is
quitting has helped over 300
000 people stop sleeping and they are
helping hundreds and thousands
more and i just think that is amazing
and to further
you know set in the fact that having a
support system is amazing
over this whole past year if it wasn't
for my own friends that i relied on and
you know my tight-knit group of people
that i you know supported me through my
toughest times
i would have been so stressed out trying
to get through
all of this and anxiety is already a
super huge thing
that i deal with and a lot of people
don't know this but vaping actually
increases your anxiety it does the
opposite of what a lot of people
usually think so today we're gonna have
some fun we're gonna rely on the power
of friendship
and teamwork and we are going to put our
contestants today
through this escape the room themed
island that i've created if anybody ever
has gone and checked out escape the room
games
irls and it's all about the teamwork and
communicating
and making sure that you guys can get
through it together so i've tried to
build a lot of these around that thing
to help so i'm really really excited
thank you everyone in the chat
tuning in i'm gonna try to keep an eye
on what's going on over here
while i'm helping our contestants i'm
really excited because the first
challenge i am sending our contestants
all the way through
the pitfall forest ooh very
spoopy and scary
and their goal is to find all of the
shovels they need
to get through the bushes that are
blocking their way to the next path
and although it seems like a lot working
together
and having a support system is going to
make it easier right so
i'm really excited we have our
contestants here um
three hopefuls who are going to get
through all challenges um we're supposed
to have four contestants today
unfortunately one of our contestants
could not make it but
it's all right i'm wishing them well
hoping everything's okay so we have
three
contestants here and we have four
challenges that we're going to
put them through it's going to be very
very exciting so let me
make sure they're ready
[Music]
i'm using a little keyboard on my switch
so make sure they're ready
make sure they are excited and
yeah kind of getting their thinking caps
on because
i have tried to hide these shovels in
very interesting places and obviously
it's the pitfall forest so it's going to
be very
very interesting to see how they do this
all right but the most important thing
just like quitting vaping
it's not easy but you're not in this
alone and that's something that our
players are gonna start so here we go
pitfall
forest let's see proceed
to the forest
good luck oh wait and
all right i did ask them to listen into
the intro as well so that they can
also
hear some of the rules i guess you know
i planted these in very sneaky areas
so i'm gonna try to put myself in
positions that are
not in the way uh-huh see you see what i
did there
oh we got another one
i
so all of these shovels
are hidden around they're gonna have to
find
how to get these ones out of the center
maybe there will be a few
that are uh that you don't have to dig
out
we'll see i'm gonna really try also not
to fall into my
own pitfall traps
[Laughter]
because that would be devastating as
well
um which by the way when you're building
stuff like this and it's nearing
completion it gets harder and harder not
to fall into your own traps
so yeah
but yeah and sorry guys
the code is not open to everyone this
has been something we've been planning
for a really long time
and we got our contestants here um but
in the future
you know we're always trying to have
more of these streams for you guys we're
always trying to make
more ooh balance some software that's
another big thing here you guys
so our players are not on voice con so
everything that they have to do
they have to communicate to each other
through pets
so it adds to the challenge a little bit
but you know
still a very viable form of
communication
we also have red on our island today
which is really exciting
thank you so much yo friends and happy
friday thank you so much for tuning in
and happy friday to everyone else as
well
oh snap looks like casey found
the first shovel and picked up another
shovel but as you may have noticed right
there
the shovels are one-time use so they're
gonna have to
think really long and hard about where
and when they're gonna use it
[Music]
[Music]
i've like tried to make this so that
wouldn't be too hard it wouldn't be too
easy
so sick one for the team
yes the pitfall forest
flames another oh ho
i see i see they've decided to open this
bush over here which is very
interesting i'm curious to see what they
do
[Music]
yes indeed the pit fall forest
is a treacherous treacherous place
and interestingly enough choosing to go
the complete
long way around so you know
there's not only one way to get around
places in
[Music]
and which areas are actually just
you know leading them astray this is why
sometimes
you know if you feel like you don't know
which way to go you gotta consult
with the people around you need ladder
oh see we've got some good communication
i really love it interestingly with that
they're all going down this
treacherous path but i know one of them
did find the secret path oh
see here we go very interesting let's
see oh i
almost thought i ran into my own pitfall
and i i just don't want to
all right so junk has found
see they're starting to think they're
like hold up
i don't know if i want to go down this
crazy path i know that there is another
way
oh and they got they're combining their
resources seriously
[Music]
yes hello everyone in chat i'm sorry i'm
like watching
this unfold and i'm like oh my goodness
i just
watching unfold i like seeing how other
people are like going through this
little puzzle that i've
created so what is up hello
hello chad how's it going are you
enjoying
your time so far because i am i'm i'm
applauding casey here for
pushing on through this path
they are accumulating
accumulating their resources i honestly
don't remember which one of these are
all going to try my best
[Music]
it's dancing stuck in there
oh this is great this is great
okay however i'm curious when they're
gonna start using
these shovels on here because this is
actually where they need to go to
advanced
to the next challenge so
here we've got so many people i know
let's see if i can help give them a clue
she's making it quite a way through
but you know i'm giving her a huge huge
hint right here
where could it be
all right let's see if i can help them i
wonder what else
oh i almost ran into my own
i almost ran into my own bedball let's
not do that
[Music]
oh
[Music]
yes it is happening they're figuring it
out
[Music]
alrighty
oh yeah the realization i kind of love
it actually
a lot because that's like what i wanted
to happen
like oh
[Music]
she's still going for it i hear it i
you know i put all the pitfalls to kind
of deter
others from going around
but she persevered she
persevered yeah and then here comes
that couldn't have gone better oh no
yeah all right yeah guys you definitely
don't
have to proceed anymore
and it looks like the leg is the first
one
to make it over to the
well it's not really a secret it's on
the map you can see everybody
everything on the map which i tried to
keep in mind
oh hold on i forgot to
[Music]
i thought i sent everyone one
wait
oh no typos
[Music]
some of these i was hoping that they
weren't in too
difficult of places to find
so we'll see we shall see
uh i kind of made this really difficult
for myself to
show you guys i do everything
there are a total of i will give you
guys
i'm actually using my keyboard i hooked
up the keyboard to the usb slot on my
switch dock
because it's completely difficult we
need a ladder
meg is so smart i do
think there is a portion
of the lobby area that they have not
discovered yet
so i'm gonna run over there while
they're not looking
[Music]
so that they can see so i can show you
guys
oh no don't i will not be
full of my own traps okay so while
they're over there
not looking let me show you guys
[Music]
super fun i kind of love hiding stuff
[Music]
and they're
[Music]
[Music]
wow
found the ladder very nice very nice
the progress being made there are many
layers
to this forest
yes success found
the ladder
oh wait no i should do encouragement
[Music]
behind the first shoe
yeah meg found everyone's vaulting pole
that was needed
[Music]
so you know although casey did you know
tough it out like a champ
and took all the pitfalls i will say
i did give options to not go that way it
was just you know
so let's see if they have found the
other
the other shovels
i hope they didn't use some of them on
things that
weren't because
if that happens
i have a really i have one hidden really
well
but i i'm gonna wait and see before i
throw out more hints
where how to get there
[Music]
oh thank you guys so much in the chat i
worked so hard on this and it was super
super fun
like some of the funnest things that i
could do it's pretty great
so i will save the biggest plan here to
get everyone to work together
communicate you know share items
give each other options or like give
each other resources
i think that's really awesome it's
working exactly yes
[Music]
yes i love it
so some of these i made it so that they
had to
not only pull the ball but also ladder
so they needed both so they really will
have to share with each other to get to
certain places and work together
to reach these goals
[Music]
may i have a ball yeah now you have
three balls
i love this though so great
nice nice there's another one hidden
here
but i'm not going to tease it yet
because honestly they might have found
it already
i don't know if they did or not but they
might
oh no lost in the pitfalls
[Music]
sneaky hidden soul
let me see how many
i really love hiding so two
all right so i got two two four
five okay
[Music]
i believe in you guys
[Music]
i love this so much hello good skeleton
welcome happy friday
no shovels are buried
[Music]
oh no wait why can't you get over here
oh someone's standing there
[Music]
so they have five right so five
all right while they run away
[Music]
hello
[Music]
i'm hiding this light on females
yay one step
closer
all right so we definitely have
two three
there's still three by the museum
[Music]
there's ten bushes but they have to get
through
you got it okay um
i don't know if they found the other
let's
eat
[Music]
unless they found these already let's
check
[Music]
we're good if they find those two then
they can see it's going to be no no i
must run away
it's like among us they must run away
from the scene of the crimes
don't follow me i i hold no inspiration
i'm just kidding oh they're making
it through this is exciting
you love to see things come to fruition
right all the hard work you put into
something and seeing it happen
you know you gotta celebrate these
little victories sometimes and that's
like
that goes for everyday life not just in
animal crossing
you know not just you know anything like
every small victory you get you deserve
to celebrate that
so let's see how far they get they
should have all
except for the final
the final two my day is going very very
well thank you so much for asking
i hope your day is going good as well i
hope you're enjoying our little maze
it's been super fun do we have enough
ooh the ultimate question
[Music]
michael oh oops
okay i was like oh oops that one was
definitely supposed to break
you know i definitely went and took a
flimsy shovel and hit a rock
39 times to get these one hit shovels
okay
two more
more where could these last two be
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
that lobby be nice
[Laughter]
[Music]
oh yeah
[Music]
exciting you just restarted your animal
frosting oh
[Music]
hello chad so sorry guys this is a
private puzzle event that we've got
going on
of course our stream today is sponsored
by
truth we are powered by truth and
we are you know helping our contestants
get through all these puzzles with
great support with them much like this
is quitting does
and it can actually help you with your
process and your journey
to ditch vaping as well if you guys want
to learn more you can text
ditch babe to 8870199
it looks like our contestants are almost
through the first
challenge one
more
yay
we did it all right challenge number one
down now our contestants will
separate to their respective rooms
let me read the chat
[Music]
so our next
[Music]
all right so we've separated by t-shirt
these designs
are exclusive truth merge designs
and we've separated our teams into two
i'll go to the other side since one of
our
lonely teammates
okay here we go never alone though never
look
why you guys because the homies are here
that's why all right so as you can tell
each room both looks like this well
i only came to this one see like you
guys
each room will have to be
replicated they will have to move items
from the orange squares
to the white orange circles excuse me to
the white circles but they have to be
matching so they'll have to communicate
with each other
to make sure they put each piece in the
correct spot and
they have to stop the wheel on the same
number
there is a little twist though and i'll
show you right now
am i allowed to see them
[Music]
no oops capslock i don't want to yell at
them
[Music]
so as you can see that room looks like
that but if you go over
the other side it is the same
but you might notice something a little
bit
different
[Music]
all right so it looks the same but a
little bit different
the rooms are actually rotated 90
degrees
so that's going to be the challenge you
know not everybody views things the same
way
so not everyone can be helped the same
way
and so learning how to not only concerns
with that but also
having people around you who can
understand that you know each
point of view is unique and each path
on your journey is unique and getting
through it together
so nice we're seeing the communication
start
bookshelf let's see table
right all right casey is acknowledging
what she's saying here
very nice
i like this this is interesting i
assume they would be more like oh i'm
gonna put this item next to this thing
but right now they're verifying
everything is the same and everything
exists which is pretty cool
confirming they also have the same
amount of items i like this the teamwork
a little ways hello
see this one was interesting because
this point of view
you can't really see this chair
sometimes not everyone sees the same
things
but with the proper communication
they can see what each other
i don't know i tried to really
emphasize it here you guys like you're
never alone seriously
[Music]
[Music]
although this room that i just left has
two players
and the other um oh thank you guys so
much
for subscribing definitely hit a like on
the video as well
and just have a good time
so i totally forgot
i got subscribed to my
um
okay so oh yeah i remember it so the
other room has two players and this room
only has one player but i really like
that the room of two players
that's one of the two players is
listening to our solo player here and
kind of letting them
follow shots which is which is really
nice because sometimes
people think if you have more people on
the other side they might chime up more
and kind of be the shot caller but i
really appreciate them listening
and don't underestimate the power
it can really help people more than you
[Music]
know
oh this was another thing i was very
curious to see
with how would um i was curious to see
how long it would take to
to figure out that the rooms were not
facing the same direction and they
actually figured that out pretty quick
they've only been on this challenge for
about
seven minutes so that's pretty great
oh it's 90 degrees casey
[Music]
90 degrees very smart very wonderful
i love it this is so fun i don't know i
don't know this type of stuff is very
fun for me
like when you craft something and it
works out that's really good
i don't know my friends here are having
fun
they figured that out really quick like
i said very nice i was
worried it wasn't gonna be very
explanatory but
and then i'm just gonna go back and
forth and make sure everyone is placing
things
in the same spot and once it's all
matched boom
they've succeeded
[Music]
i just like using the little mario
travel type thing
it's very convenient especially when i
was building this i
put one near my house and one near um
like the town square and all the main
stuff so i could have easy travel all
the buildings
and you know with all of these things
going on being able to like
stop and communicate and figure things
out
you know there's power behind that as
well i feel like
at least
[Music]
problem solving is fun
puzzles
[Music]
[Music]
got it
[Music]
all right we have successfully placed
the brand
[Music]
uh-oh whoa looks like we have some
miscommunication
we have the branch over by the plant on
this side
see before i could even get back it was
already lined up
[Music]
very nice very nice
i think the fun part really is going to
be
getting them both to stop this wheel on
the same number
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
all right what else do they have now
spinner without all the items let's see
let's see let's do a little test here
all right
all right they're missing yet where's
the blossom i was gonna i was just about
to save
[Music]
[Music]
i think they rolled it again right after
the two
[Music]
oh you got one
[Music]
[Music]
challenge my typos
[Music]
all right
[Music]
okay you guys so another
big thing for
our games today is that we do have all
of
the cute san miguel villages on the
island you know they're brand new here
they just became available for animal
crossing and
we gotta make them some homework gifts
right housewives
home warming i don't know it's one of
those things but sometimes
something that helps me out when i'm
feeling kind of stressed or something
or i'm missing someone or anything like
that i kind of like to do some arts and
crafts to like
make things and especially making things
for friends
can be very relaxing and also just like
that serotonin boost looks like
making something special whoa
no shopping and kind of just making uh
making things for people you care about
it's really fun so we're gonna make some
gifts for our friends
we've put some notes on the bulletin
board to see
what our friends might like so i left
some notes
you know about what marty likes and what
chai would like
and our contestants are going to have to
go digging in the museum's dig site
look for items uh the materials
and if they don't have any other recipes
well i also have all the rescues down
here at the bottom just in case
i try to pick some common ones that
people most likely have
and and
there's a crosstalking binge inside
so i'm excited about that because it
made it easy to put this little area
together because i knew the crafting bin
she was already there
um so they're finding the materials i
like that they've divvied up some stuff
already it seems you know
let's dig up things find all the
ingredients
one person's already getting the ball
rolling on the crafting
and they're also picking up clothing
items
which is very important as well because
one of our next is coming up
is going to be involving those items so
they will have to hold on to them
[Music]
make the clock
so i am going to split up the wrapping
papers
so that after i inspect the item that
they make they can wrap it
and then place it on the appropriate
person's
school
so far so good so far they also have
hats
yes oh that reminds me too the
customization kits
they also have to customize the item to
the correct thing
as well you know you can customize items
um my favorite villager on animal
crossing
is actually fauna i love fauna so much
she's on my personal island she's not on
the gamespot island but she's on my
personal island
i love her so much she's so cute and
she's just chilling all the time i love
it um so that's my favorite what about
you guys what's your favorite
who is your favorite villager as well
[Music]
so something else too they will need
customization
put a few around here as well but they
can come hang out
[Music]
[Music]
uh
because i keep looking down at the
keyboard this keyboard is so old that
some of the letters have
like rubbed off
[Music]
[Music]
so after they make it after they
customize it
then i'll take a look to make sure it's
the right thing and wrap it up for our
new friends
and i have the list written down right
in front of me
[Music]
because it's like six specific items
for six specific characters all right
let's see
we've got canada
inspecting the iphone orange vlog
yeah okay
i've dropped the wrapping paper
[Music]
if you see paper
[Music]
[Music]
in useful very nice very nice need to
play
[Music]
the items i'm so excited you guys i feel
like the first two games went exactly
how i imagined it was very nice and
fun and this is also going very well
you know when you build stuff like this
you always have these worries that maybe
you forgot something
you forgot to put something down on the
island
and the important things to know is that
even if something like that happens
it's fine you can work through it you
can come up with a plan
that's honestly why i have a bunch of
extra materials because i was
i'm so certain i might have forgot a
piece or two and they won't be able to
make one of these but it's fine
i try my best i'm pretty sure we're good
etswah's
gift is done it's so exciting
i love all
let me show you guys the map real quick
so all of our villagers are indeed up
here in their special
area waiting for our next task
just looking at the map after like
creating the whole news is just really
fun
and also you know i had to make some
letters over there on the right side
which was also very very fun
so i'm loving this island right now it's
been really really cool to me
and the games are going flawlessly
[Music]
all materials have been received
[Music]
they are sprinkled around
[Music]
everything looks super good thank you so
much
[Music]
and the cool thing about the english
dish sets is that you can customize
those all these really cute colors
okay inspection grass standy
i actually can't check to see if they
customize themselves i'm just going to
have to trust
that they do
[Music]
oh
[Music]
yes
we are looking for more customization
yes meg is so quick with it
[Music]
megan's so smart this group here you
guys they are very smart so i had to up
the challenge a bit
to keep it interesting for the friends
i'm gonna stand here because this is a
i don't want them to go that way yet
that's the next challenge
[Music]
[Music]
whoops
i knew that might have been a thing like
it's the only thing i can't really check
because they don't let you put items
like place items when other people are
on your island i was like we'll just get
as close as we can
[Music]
i think
[Music]
morty pants
[Music]
i have to make
but yes you guys if you're just now
tuning in
our stream today is powered by truth
and there this is quitting initiative to
help
young adults and everyone really to
ditch
vaping you guys despite what you might
know
vaping does not help with anxiety or
anything like that and
it actually raises it so that's just one
of many things
that kind of detriments me from ever
ever going back
but you know it's also difficult it's
not easy and that's why this is quitting
is
down to help anybody 24 7 you know and
kind of at your own pace everyone's
experience is different kind of like how
we mentioned before
but this is quitting is really there to
help support you and help you find ways
to stop so if you want to learn more you
can text
ditch vape 28709 to learn more
and you know parents if there's any
parents tuning in as well
you can also check there and get
resources to
help your your son or daughter or child
and yeah just know you're not alone no
one's alone
we're all in this together need a paper
boom oh
the dish set that is now customized
success
reaction
[Music]
what other gifts do we still need
four real ones let's see what did we
have done
we have she needs that wooden in
table you guys that's what an intable is
calling her name we're close though
really need chelsea's gifts
[Music]
so like any good escape the room
sometimes things you've picked up way
earlier in the round
will be useful way later in the game
and i've kind of tried to apply that as
well
so some of the items they may have found
in the first challenge
um or the this challenge is gonna help
them in the next challenge
so we are indeed making
[Music]
two more gifts to be done meg is like
you know what
i made enough gifts i'ma have a seat
i mean fair these challenges were wrong
they fell through a mini of pitfall
seeds so i don't blame them at all
oh hello and chad unfortunately this
event was something that we have already
scheduled ahead of time
but we're definitely planning on having
another animal crossing stream soon
so if you guys are interested then keep
an eye out i'll probably
be sending the signal out to social
media
you'll find some more contestants for
next time or players who are interested
in
going through this crazy island
um every time we do this island is a
little bit different though so
next time it may not be like this maybe
something completely new so if you've
seen it once it doesn't mean you've seen
it all you guys
hopefully the next time is even more you
know this was a good test though
i tried to make it so it was difficult
but it's too hard
um and you know
[Music]
um and we've only got so much time
to like get through all of this fun
stuff so
so far it's going on i'm excited
i had to clear the dug up holes over
there
it was just bothering me
okay all right two more gifts left
dropped the customization kits tom nook
is like look at all of these new friends
here
building gifts for our new residents i'm
sure tom nick loves it
hmm i was waiting to see if anybody
would find the customization kits right
behind chai's portrait
but i honestly put enough that i don't
think they'll need all of those
you know just in case they didn't find
it
[Music]
aha
communicating you know a big part of
communication guidance is
not only listening but responding
you know confirming someone needs
something
you know confirm with them yes
like i can help you or maybe we you know
if you can't help someone you can help
them find someone
like texting ditch base 2
88709 for more information on
wooden vaping um but yeah that's
also something i feel like i've been
trying to be better at in general
communication definitely
[Music]
wait
[Music]
there we go yeah i tried to put the
exact amount of like
every item in the dig site
it's really hard to like walk off every
way to get through somewhere
without totally shutting myself out here
yeah junk had all the wind all the
resources
[Music]
oh snap is this the wooden end table
pick it up
yes it is
[Music]
and we shall also drop a wrapping paper
and drop yeah and give it a little clap
yeah okay
[Music]
i'm just gonna stand here and see if
anybody noticed
[Music]
super secret hiding places
so the next challenge is also a little
bit
you know them searching for things that
are very well hidden
um but yeah this is the
final final challenge
still missing one piece of wood
[Music]
oops
[Music]
i wonder how many
[Music]
ah i have none oh no
i did miss one piece of wood of course i
did
and i left it in the house
well
[Music]
hello
[Music]
darn all right you know what though guys
i almost had everything on i just missed
one piece of wood
you know this wasn't quite what i meant
when i
said things from the beginning we're
gonna incorporate it
[Music]
i'm just you know being a cameraman
casey don't mind me
i'm the camera person
here we go let's see how much luck do we
get
getting one wood
how many chops you know actually this
was all a part of the plan
you know guys
there we go this is all over little plan
that one
missing
[Music]
the one missing lead you know
calculated
it's fine it works
the solutions problem solved
yes and then we enjoy a little dance
wait i want to
do i love the new emotes you guys
they're so cute
i don't want to dance yet
i don't even know which one the dance is
i guess
not that one
maybe i don't have that one yet it's so
cute
i like that one too
[Music]
all right the final gift is being made
we're dancing a little here
in the square i don't think i have this
super adorable but i can work out
it is done nice
let's just inspect these
items
[Music]
amazing
[Music]
oh i missed it
[Music]
all right let us spin the confirmation
challenge
now we proceed to our final
[Music]
challenge
[Music]
yeah all right you guys we
are approaching our final challenge
of the day now
[Music]
welcome
[Music]
so i did explain to the contestants each
challenge a little bit beforehand so i
wouldn't have to type so much
right now but basically
each villager the san ono villagers
as you guys know are based on certain
characters
so while our new villagers were flying
over this was just a little story i made
up in my head for this challenge but
while our new abilities were flying in
you know moving in
uh some of the luggage fell off the dodo
plane on the way over
but it's fine because our contestants
are gonna go find all their luggage
and deliver it to their house for
be an them at all so then i'll have to
find out where it all goes this is
willow's house and you can
definitely tell because gorilla is based
off of hello kitty in this house just
screams
[Music]
oh
[Music]
you're so cute
[Music]
exploring because you know when luggage
fell out of
dodo planes it just all landed on this
section
of the island so
it's fine though this is what our
players are here for you know the
luggage
rescue team is here no matter what crazy
stuff happens or goes on
you can make it through and honestly one
time when i flew
from texas to new york a long long long
time ago
there's a huge blizzard and my luggage
got lost too and i didn't have any of my
luggage for like
almost two weeks it was pretty crazy
um so luckily for our new friends on the
island i'm actually so happy they're
walking around outside they're so
cute luckily
our new friends will get their items
back asap
but the other part of the puzzle is also
figuring out
and remembering which character each and
we have to
face off obviously the hello kitty ones
are super easy
amazing amazing
a lot of the stuff was mixed in with the
last challenge
in the big bite
[Music]
them
asking for help though is so important
and you know doing it early on see and
here we go no don't have fear
[Music]
love it love it love it
but that's so important asking for help
when you need it
it's totally fine totally fine
and something you can do if you're
trying to
split basically you can text stitch face
and learn more about truth's this is
quitting program which is actually why
we're here sitting we're obviously
having fun we are thriving off of the
power of friendship right now
but we're also really excited to be
sharing
[Music]
coming together slowly but surely
junk is dropping off all this house he's
been out there
hoarding investigating discovering
wow that's at least that's almost
all the shoes left i think there's four
shoes here
[Music]
[Music]
there's one that's in a very interesting
spot but
[Music]
they found the ones that were definitely
up top
very good very good
some of the ones i put out here
[Music]
they were this far they weren't exactly
[Music]
nice they found the
[Music]
oh yes delivering all this luggage
back to us our new friends are gonna be
so happy
because i know maybe they're mine look
at my door i almost cried tears of joy i
was
so happy to see my stuff again
[Music]
[Music]
of course i made it but except for this
time i'm not going to
tell them
but if they really really do need help
then of course
[Music]
i think of all the items that i hid this
one was definitely
the like trickiest one for sure
but they're searching they're looking
i'll give them a few more minutes to
search on their own
i believe them i believe they can find
it
i don't want to write around too much
and give it away let's hang out over
here
toby do you know where this is do you
know where it is
do you know where it is shelby what
about you everybody
do you know where it is oh she knows she
knows
she was looking at it
[Music]
red is here indeed
they were all talking about it when they
first got here like red is here
i have to go check out red yes please
while you're here but the shirt is not
over there my friends
it really is i believe in the vote i
believe
whoever finds is gonna feel like the
world's biggest genius
[Music]
i knew they would find it i know
i had all the things but i also need two
ways to get there
i also need this
[Music]
i also made this avenue to get there as
well
so that if they didn't have one then
they had the other
oh send me back
success yay
they did it
[Music]
now for one little challenge
now join me for some
yoga
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
we're going to do a little bit of yoga
we did a lot of running around
we did a lot of you know action-packed
things
[Music]
we really relax set in
and breathe sometimes
we're always on the go we're always on
the go we're always trying
to get things done and we're always
trying to find things to help us do that
hopefully something you guys can say is
that you can rely on your support system
or if you feel like you don't have a
support system
then you can rely on just quitting by
shooting that text message out if you're
feeling like you need a little bit of
help and a little bit of encouragement
to ditch saving and don't forget
facing although it might seem like
people do it to ease their anxiety it's
not
the opposite so maybe consider doing a
little bit of yoga instead
picking up some healthy habits maybe
trying out some arts and crafts like we
were doing earlier with the gifts it was
really really
fun helping out friends you know and
who are also in need of health can be
very rewarding
in its own health so i love this so much
i actually want to take a photo of all
of us
doing our yoga with our little t-shirts
i love it let me make sure i turn my
yoga yoga
yes i love it
absolutely getting those stretches in
and it's peaceful so you can hear the
sound of the fountain
everything beautiful and wonderful
i had a lot of fun today you guys i hope
you
also had a lot of fun our contestants
they knocked it out of the park they
communicated with each other the entire
time
they found all of these really well
hidden items
that i scattered across the entire
island and
they executed every challenge really
flawlessly
though and sometimes it can be hard all
via text only
because our contestants were not on
voice chat it was all text
so that goes to show you the power of
even
text and not just spoken words but even
peps can have a super huge effect you
can get a lot of things done
and you know i'm going to say it again
if you guys are looking
for resources or help or just someone to
talk to
especially when you're trying to ditch
vaping and finding resources around that
then please please please reach out and
check out this is quitting go ahead and
text
ditchvape288709 to find out more or
visit the website
hundreds of thousands of people are
getting help and it's really beautiful
to see it so
i hope you guys had so much fun today
and i hope you enjoyed our stream and
enjoyed our games
i hope you take into consideration that
you could do a little bit of yoga
sometimes
to maybe use that or maybe try
meditation or even working out you know
what i'm also going to
put my workout email on because working
out is also something that a lot of my
friends really turn to to help as well
so let's do this you guys i believe
all of you remember you know
don't be scared to reach out don't be
scared to find that support system you
are
not alone at all so hope you enjoyed
thank you so much to all of our
contestants and i'm just very at peace
right now having a great time hope you
guys tune in again like i said before
this is not gonna be the last stream
we're gonna have another one so if
you're interested in being a contestant
for
the next one then keep an eye out on the
social media feeds because i will be
shooting out the signal to get more
people to play and
hopefully do this again i have a super
fun time hope you guys did too
stay safe stay happy have a great
weekend
and i will see you next time goodbye
you